l'ordre du jour appelle le vote solennel
sur le projet de loi constitutionnel
relatif à la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse nous allons passer aux
explications de vote 5 minutes par
groupe un orateur par groupe le premier
va être Monsieur Laurent panifous pour
le groupe liberté indépendant outre M et
territoire
prés cette fois-ci
je madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues les
avancées consacrées par la loi veille il
ilant 47 ans sont désormais acceptés par
une immense majorité de nos concitoyens
ce texte a traversé les âges pour
protéger les droits des femmes dans tous
nos territoires la question nous est
donc posée aujourd'hui sur la
possibilité d'aller plus loin d'inscrire
la liberté d'accès à l'interruction
volontaire de grossesse dans notre
Constitution comme beaucoup de mes
collègues comme jean-phélix Aquaviva
chef de file sur ce texte je tiens à
rendre hommage au combat mené par Simon
veille en
1975 ce combat pour le droit des femmes
est entré dans l'histoire mais reste
d'actualité il ne tient qu'à nous de le
prolonger et de le consacrer
solennellement dans notre norme la plus
élevée les Françaises nous écoutent avec
une attention particulière aujourd'hui
j'aimerais d'abord répondre à ceux qui
laisse entendre que nous serions
suffisamment protégés en France qui n'it
nul besoin de sécuriser l'IVG je leur
dirai que l'optimisme est une qualité
mais qu'elle ne doit pas amener à
l'aveuglement la loi veille est une
garantie essentiel pour le droit à l'IVG
mais ce droit reste dans la loi
ordinaire une autre loi pourrait donc le
limiter le restreindre et revenir sur
ses acquis il peut également y avoir des
revirements jurisprudentiels conduisant
à des décisions inattendues que ce soit
dans le bon sens mais aussi dans le
mauvais inutile d'aller jusqu'aux
États-Unis pour trouver des exemples
inquiétants on entouvre déjà ici parmi
les pays membres de l'Union européenne
en Pologne c'est le Tribunal
constitutionnel qui a réduit de manière
drastique l'accès à l'avortement à
rebour de l'équilibre juridique qu'il
avait trouvé dans les années 90 le
gouvernement portugais a quant à lui
décidé en 2015 de mettre à la charge des
femmes tous les frais Liers à l'arrêt de
leur grossesse en Espagne un projet de
loi approuvé en 2013 en conseil des
ministres prévoyait de limiter les Vig
au cas de grave danger pour la santé de
la mère ou de viol avant d'être retiré
devant le tolé suscité dans notre pays
il existe aussi certains organ militant
contre la protection de l'ivigier
souvenez-vous qu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps en janvier 2020 une campagne
antivg avait été affiché dans les
espaces publicitaires du métro de notre
capitale c'est vrai pour l'instant en
France aucun mouvement politique
d'ampleur ne demande l'abolition pure et
simple du droit à l'IVG est-ce pour cela
qu'il faut ne rien faire devrions-nous
rester les bras croisés sous prétexte
que le danger de voir ce droit amoindri
n'est pas encore devant la porte de
notre assemblée je crois au contraire
que nous devons agir pendant que nous le
pouvons tant qu'une majorité d'entre
nous est contre tout recul je veux dire
à cet hémicycle que l'improbable n'est
pas impossible et que c'est'est bien le
rôle d'un élu d'un représentant de la
nation d'anticiper et d'agir même face à
ce qui est aujourd'hui considéré comme
hautement
incertain ne prenons pas de risque ne
parions pas sur un sujet aussi important
le droit à l'IVG fait pleinement partie
de notre contrat social le droits des
femmes sont des droits fondamentaux
l'IVG mérite d'être inscrit au sein de
notre Constitution à ceux qui disent que
nous sommes dans le symbole je veux dire
qu'il ne s'agit aucunement de faire
semblant mais de renforcer une
protection ordinaire pour lui offrir un
bouclier constitutionnel à la hauteur
des enjeux aussi nous nous rangeons
derrière la rédaction de compromis
proposé par le gouvernement que nous
avons adopté la semaine dernière
privilégiant la notion de liberté et
l'inscription à l'article 34 de la
Constitution la notion de droit à l'IVG
était préférable pour bon nombre de
membres de mon groupe mais le débat
entre les forces politiques permet aussi
d'évoluer et dans le but de
rassemblement nous l'acceptons mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui je fais le choix
de renforcer les acquis de la loi veille
en actant cette consécration au rang
constitutionnel je terminerai en
insistant sur la notion d'égalité
d'accès à l'IVG pour les femmes qui le
souhaite des difficultés pratiques et
des fractures sociales et territoriales
élevées persistent en France nous devons
travailler à garantir un accès effectif
à l'IVG cela impose une réponse forte de
l'État monsieur le ministre la très
grande majorité des membres de mon
groupe votera favorablement cette
avancée en faveur du droit des femmes et
de la liberté de choisir ou non de
donner la vie je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue pour le
groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Madame Sarah
tonzili
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le gardessau monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous voici sur le point de
franchir une étape cruciale du processus
entamé dès les premiers jours de notre
législature avec le dépôt de plusieurs
propositions de révision
constitutionnelle de la majorité comme
de l'opposition permettant de
sanctuariser le droit à l'avortement
nous nous avons longuement débattu ici
même et en commission et ce débat trouve
un large écho en dehors de nos murs car
les Françaises et les Français en ont
bien compris l'enjeu c'est bien les
droits de nos filles et de nos petites
filles que nous sommes sur le point de
protéger c'est bien les contour de la
société française de demain que nous
allons désormais
garantir ce débat a permis je crois de
dissiper les derniers doutes les
dernières interrogations sincères non la
constitutionnalisation de la liberté
garantie à la femme de recourir à l'IVG
n'entraînera pas de modification des
modalités actuelles d'exercice de ce
droit ni sur le délis durant lequel une
femme peut avorter ni sur les modalités
d'accès ni sur la clause de conscience
dont bénéficient les soignants et dont
la portée constitutionnelle a déjà été
garanti par le juge non le droit de
recourir à l'IVG n'est actuellement
protégé par aucune norme
supralégislative de sorte que si nous ne
parvenions pas à faire aboutir cette
réforme constitutionnelle une simple loi
ordinaire pourrait tout à fait venir
effacer l'édifice juridique qu'une
succession de lois a créé en un
demi-siècle comme l'a dit à très juste
titre le rapporteur ce texte c'est rien
et tout à la fois certes il ne modifie
pas le cadre juridique actuel mais il
pourrait devenir demain le seul rempart
le seul bouclier du droit des femmes
contre une majorité parlementaire
réactionnaire car il est certain que les
circonstances politiques nous incitent à
passer à l'acte maintenant oui le droit
à l'avortement est bien plus menacé
qu'auparavant croire que l'exemple
américain est une exception culturelle
circonscrite dans le temps l'espace et
limité à une culture politique à
laquelle nous serions par nature
hermétique c'est faire preuve d'un
optimisme naïf que je ne peux partager
il n'est d'ailleurs pas nécessaire de
franchir l'océan pour constater que les
majorités réactionnaires font toujours
du droit à l'avortement des femmes une
de leurs premières cibles la Pologne la
Hongrie Malte l'Italie l'Espagne le
Portugal toutes des démocraties qui ont
vu des majorit parlementaire mettre en
œuvre ou tenter de mettre en œuvre des
politiques qui mettent à mal le droit à
l'IVG jusqu'à forcer les femmes à
écouter les battements de cœur du fétus
ou à interdire l'avortement même en cas
de malformation fétale et en France
alors ici même devrais-je dire
devons-nous prendre pour argent comptant
la promesse proférée la main sur le cœur
par ceux qui étaient contre le droit à
l'avortement hier qu'on ne les y
reprendrait plus faut-il fermer les yeux
au passage de milliers de manifestants
opposés au droit à l'avortement dans les
rues de Paris comme ce fut le cas il y a
10 jours faut-il se boucher les oreilles
lorsque des parlementaires du
rassemblement national comparent
l'avortement à un génocide pardonnez-moi
mais je ne crois pas que les
réactionnaires de tout craint a changer
d'avis sur la place des femmes dans la
société et je sais que c'est en les
empêchant de maîtriser leur corps qu'il
prévoi de les renvoyer dans les foyers
voter pour ce bouclier protecteur ce
n'est pas faire preuve de pessimisme
c'est faire preuve de responsabilité
c'est anticiper des évolutions probables
particulièrement néfastes avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard pour nous en prém unir
mes chers collègues je crois que nous
pouvons être fi du travail accompli et
je tiens à saluer tout particulièrement
l'esprit de responsabilité de plusieurs
des groupes politiques de notre
assemblée qui ont accepté de se ranger
derrière la rédaction de compromis
proposés par le gouvernement une
formulation équilibrée qui préserve la
volonté du Sénat tout en protégeant
efficacement les modalités d'exercice du
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans ces conditions ce
compromis ne pourra souffrir aucun recul
sous peine de voir disparaître le
bouclier protecteur non agressif que
nous appelons de nos vœux car comment le
juge constitutionnel interprèteil un
interpréterait-il un reculle en
particulier le fait de retrancher le mot
garantie autrement que comme une volonté
du constituant de ne pas garantir la
liberté donnée à la femme de recourir à
l'avortement nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre une telle ambiguïé alors que
ce texte s'apprête à poursuivre son
parcours parlementaire je forme le vœux
qu'il soit regardé par nos collègues
sénateurs pour ce qu'il est un pas vers
l'autre pour la défense d'intérêts qui
nous dépasse un compromis entre la
gauche qui a abandonné beaucoup je le
sais la majorité et la droite
républicaine et je ne doute pas du fait
que le Sénat chambre du compromis et de
la mesure entend notre appel à l'unité
républicaine pour le droit des femmes
mes chers collègues le droit des femmes
de disposer de leur corps de choisir
leur destin de faire seul les choix qui
les concernent n'est pas une humeur une
concession donnée à l'air du temps ou à
des prescripteurs de moral venus de
l'étranger il est la source même de la
liberté des femmes accepté comme des
individus libres dotés de raisons et
jouissant de leurs droits de citoyennne
cette liberté là essentielle trouve sa
place dans notre Constitution pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe Renaissance
votera bien sûr en faveur de ce projet
de loi
constitutionnelle je vous remercie ma
cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Pascale
bord pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle pour voter sur un texte qui
est à tout le moins très éloigné des
aspirations actuelles de nos concitoyens
c'est ce que j'évoqué la semaine
dernière en préambule de mon propos mais
aujourd'hui avec la colère immense des
agriculteurs français partout sur notre
territoire c'est particulièrement criant
de vérité à ce moment précis à ce moment
précis à l'heure où les agriculteurs
première victime de l'écologie punitive
impulsé par l'Union européenne qui a
décidé de les sacrifier viennent à Paris
viennent à Paris crier leur désespérance
immense face à une situation qui leur
échappe et à certains politiques qui ne
les entendent pas ces agriculteurs qui
viennent également interpeller les
parlementaires que nous sommes sur les
problématiques de leur profession
comment chers collègues comment dans ces
conditions pouvons-nous consacrer autant
de temps à un texte qui vise à
constitutionnaliser l'IVG alors que le
débat sur l'IVG a eu lieu je vous le
rappelle il y en a qui l'ont oublié il y
a presque 50 ans et qu'aujourd'hui
personne absolument personne ne souhaite
dans la société française contemporaine
remettre en cause l'IVG notamment aucun
parti politique au Parlement et que
234300 IVG ont été pratiqués en 2022 en
France soit deux fois plus qu'en
Allemagne alors que la liberté de la
femme d'avorter est aujourd'hui
pleinement protégée par la loi portée
par Simone veille et qu'elle fait
désormais partie intégrante de notre
patrimoine juridique alors également que
sur le plan constitutionnel il n'y a
strictement aucun aucun risque
d'atteinte à l'IVG puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel quant à lui a toujours
jugé l'avortement conforme à la
Constitution dans ce contexte nos débats
sont à tout le moins
inaudibles aux yeux de ceux qui estiment
que nous ferions mieux de légiférer sur
les droits et libertés vous ne voulez
pas l'entendre mais vous l'entendrez sur
les droits et libertés réellement menacé
comme le droit justement de nos
agriculteurs de vivre décemment de leur
travail droit menacé par l'Union
européenne et la politique menée par les
gouvernements successifs y compris
celui-ci du président Macron ou bien ou
bien comme la liberté des femmes droit
menacé par l'islamisme galopant alors
alors pourquoi ce texte qui plus à ce
moment précis vous ne m'enlèverez pas de
l'ESIT pr que ce texte n'est qu'une pâle
diversion destiné notamment à masquer le
vrai problème à savoir la question
majeure de l'effectivité de l'accès à
l'IVG sur tout le territoire français ou
près de 50 ans et ça devrait vous
inquiéter après la loi veille nombre de
femmes au secteur rural essentiellement
ne parviennent pas à avoir recours à
univg dans les délais légaux qui ont été
repoussés précisément pour cela pour
palier les carences habissales de notre
système de santé d'cun mett avant
l'aspect symbolique de la démarche c'est
d'ailleurs pour sa portée symbolique je
le rappelle qu'une majorité de notre
groupe a voté en faveur de ce texte
soumis à notre assemblée en novembre
2022 comme la Constitution est le texte
suprême nous considérons au
rassemblement national que ce texte
devrait dans tous les cas être soumis à
référendum car la Constitution ne
devrait pouvoir être modifiée que
directement par le peuple
souverain dès lors ce texte inutile
j'insiste inutile et à rebour totalement
à rebours des attentes premières de nos
concitoyens nous devrions quand même en
avoir conscience en ces moments où nos
agriculteurs sont dans la difficulté ce
texte ne règlera pas au quotidien le
problème des femmes car il ne s'agit là
que d'une opération de communication
destinée à flatter l'ég de certains tout
en masquant tout en masquant la réalité
je l'ai dit la semaine dernière de
l'insondable état de notre me de santé
bref ce texte n'est au final qu'un
artifice pour marquer la vacuité de
votre politique de défense du droit des
femmes farouchement attaché à la liberté
de conscience le groupe rassemblement
national laissera chacun voter en
conscience je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Présidente Panau pour le pour le groupe
la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente monsieurs et
mesames les ministres
collègues nous nous tenons au seuil de
l'histoire en votant cette loi la France
va devenir le premier pays au monde à
inscrire le droit à l'avortement dans sa
constitution en votant cette loi la
France fera acte de progrès humain
collègues lorsque nous modifions la
Constitution c'est le temps long que
nous touchons du doigt oui aujourd'hui
l'histoire longue vient à notre
rencontre voter pour protéger le droit à
l'avortement dans notre norme suprême et
d'abord la consécration d'une victoire
arrachée de hautes Lutes je salue les
militantes les associations les
collectifs qui se battent des années à
ell présente en tribune je leur redis
notre
reconnaissance mvement pour de
l'avortement et de la
contraception à l'association choisir en
passant par le Mouvement français pour
le planning familial le mouvement de
libération des femmes la maîtrise de
notre destin à nous les femmes leur
doitant gloire à celles et ceux qui par
leur combat au fil du temps on arraché
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse en
1975 son remboursement par la Sécurité
Sociale en
1981 ement des délais de 10 à 12
semaines en 2001 puis de 12 à 14
semaines en 2022 et je salue la présence
d'Albane Gaillot qui nous a fait
emporter ainsi une magnifique victoire
c'est toujours grâce à elle que le droit
n'a eu de cesse de progresser droit des
mineurs à avorté sans accord parental
suppression du délai de réflexion
création du DI d'entrave autorisation
des sachamb à pratiquer des
IVG cette victoire aujourd'hui raisonne
aussi comme une réparation sinon une
revanche une revanche contre la honte la
clandestinité le silence la souffrance
la mort conduit affranter des centaines
de milliers de
femmes collègues nous nous tenons au
seuil de
l'histoire cette victoire est une
victoire
parlementaire insoumise nous sommes
fiers d'avoir été à l'origine du premier
texte voté à l'Assemblée le 24 novembre
2022 cette victoire aujourd'hui nous la
dédions aussi à toutes les femmes qui
luttent dans le monde pour le droit à
disposer d'elle-même aux femmes
italiennes hongroises aux femmes
argentines car partout où l'extrême
droite a accédé au pouvoir c'est d'abord
le droit des femmes et des LGBTQ a plus
qui ont été attaqués en premier donc ce
n'est pas un texte de communication mais
un texte de protection contre vous
l'extrême droite qui ne cessz de dire
des propos les pires propos
antiavortement et antidroit des femmes
cette victoire nous la desdion aux
femmes polonaises dont le parcours pour
légaliser l'avortement et encore semer
d' bûche aux femmes FEM états-uniennes
alors que nous apprenons que 65000
d'entre elles
65000 ont été obligé de porter l'enfant
de leur violeurs dans les états
anti-avortement à
présent nous formons le vœux que la
civilisation humaine s'engage dans le
siècle des droits des femmes collègues
nous nous tenons au seuil de l'histoire
ce texte surtout est une promesse de
sûreté une garantie à toutes celles et
ceux qui viendront après nous qu'elles
ai les M même droit que nous dans la 6e
République nous assortirons ce droit à
son corollaire celui de recourir au
droit à la
contraception souvenez-vous collègues
qu'il n'y a pas de liberté sans
autonomie loin d'un droit parmi d'autres
dans un catalogue le droit à
l'avortement est celui qui préside tous
les autres celui qui nous élève au rang
de sujet politique aujourd'hui collègu
en votant la
constitutionnalisation nous votons la
fin d'une relégation il en est assez
d'avoir été au Marg assigné de
l'histoire les femmes ne sont pas ses
utéruses à deux pattes un point c'est
tout comme écrivait Margaret hadwood ni
ses vas sacrés ni ses CALIC ambulants
notre corps nous appartient tel est le
droit fondamental et la liberté ultime
de choix que nous allons graver dans la
Constitution que nous allons graver dans
le temps long desmarg entrons maintenant
au cœur de l'histoire votons cette loi
je vous remercie madame la
présidente la parole est à Madame Émilie
Bonivard pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre madame la Présidente pardon
chers collègues nous nous apprêtons à
exercer une de nos missions les plus
fondamentales aujourd'hui le pouvoir
constituant nous nous devons de le faire
avec gravité responsabilité et en
conscience car le sujet est grave on
parle de la liberté des femmes à pouvoir
recourir à l'avortement et du respect de
la vie humaine on parle de du respect de
liberté ou droit fondamentaux or en ce
qui concerne la possibilité effective
pour les femmes de recourir à l'IVG le
fait que plus de 114 centres d'IVG et
fermé en France sous Emmanuel Macron
mettent en risque aujourd'hui le recours
réel des femmes à l'IVG dans notre pays
pose question l'inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution dans un beau
congrès des grands discours à la tribune
de la majorité du président plein de
trémolo dans la voix sur le droit des
femmes c'est bien garantir aux femmes
aujourd'hui réellement la possibilité de
recourir à l'IVG en France c'est mieux
orors si l'IVG est si important pour la
macronie pourquoi ne vous vous êtes pas
battu contre ces fermetures pourquoi vos
ministres de la Santé successif ces se
dernières années n'ont rien fait c'est
votre
responsabilité je suis à titre personnel
favorable à l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution mais en respectant
l'article 1er de la loi veille le
respect de l'être humain dès le
commencement de sa vie ce qui fait la
force de la loi veille de 75 c'est son
équilibre entre la possibilité pour la
femme d'avoir recours à l'IVG et le
respect de l'être humain dès le
commencement de sa vie c'est bien toute
la loi veille et cet équilibre que les
députés les républicains veulent
s'assurer de voir respecter car il
s'agit aujourd'hui pour nous par cette
constitutionnalisation de nous assurer
que personne ne pourra revenir en France
sur la liberté pour la femme de recourir
à l'IVG comme c'est dramatiquement le
cas aux États-Unis en Hongrie ou en
polologogne mais il s'agit tout autant
de nous prémunir contre toute véléité
d'utiliser cette inscription dans la
Constitution pour supprimer tout délai
d'IVG ou toute restriction de la clause
de conscience des soignants car si qu 80
% des Français sont favorables à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution et j'en fais partie je
pense qu'ils sont tout aussi nombreux à
rejeter l'idée de donner le droit
d'avorter par choix à 7 8 ou 9 mois je
le dis à nos concitoyens car je ne
pensait pas que c'était quelque chose
auquel on pouvait penser or force est de
constater qu'ici dans cet hémicycle
cette suppression du délai de
l'avortement n'a rien de choquante
puisque les macronistes alli à la gauche
ont voté il y a de an un amendement
permettant l'avortement jusqu'à 9 mois
pour détresses psychosocial je ne
reviendrai pas ici sur les propos d'une
association reconnue d'utilité publique
financé par l'État par de l'argent
public agréé par l'Éducation nationale
recevant et conseillur des jeunes qui
assument je cite défendre la suppression
totale du recours à l'IVG lutter pour
l'allongement des délais à l'IVG avec un
objectif premier à 24 mois c'est-à-dire
6 mois donc oui nous voulons les
républicains nous prémunir contre tous
ces excès l'IVG n'est jamais anodin ni
physiquement ni moralement il relève
bien plus de la nécessité que d'un choix
positif des femmes la liberté réelle des
femmes à disposer de leur corps ce n'est
pas de se poser la question de pouvoir
avorter à 6 7 8 ou 9 mois c'est bien de
elle se situe bien plus en amont dans la
connaissance de leur corps dans la
maîtrise de leur contraception je ne
connais pas une femme qui décide de
guêter de cœur de se faire aborter ici à
cette tribune Simon veille avait évoqué
son genre le fait d'être une femme
devant une assemblée composée d'hommes
afin de mieux immédiatement s'en
extraire pour placer son discours sur le
champ de la raison et de l'humanité
c'est ce qui a fait sa force c'est ce
qui a fait la force de sa loi c'est ce
qui a fait que cette loi é acceptée par
une immense majorité de nos concitoyens
et c'est ce que nous devons faire
aujourd'hui ici en tant que constituant
pour ma part comme constituante ma seule
upation et de défendre les principes
fondamentaux et universels de tout être
humain dont nous avons hérité par notre
Constitution d'éviter que l'un soitign
au profit de l'autre de veiller à ce que
chacun de ces droits soit soit préservé
la liberté de la femme à recourir à
l'IVG d'une part et le respect de la
dignité de la vie humaine d'autre part
aussi je voterai pour ce texte avec
exigence en préconisant le vote final du
Sénat qui me paraît bien plus protecteur
de C équilibre en refusant toute forme
d'instrumentalisation de ce droit et en
exigeant que le gouvernement mette ses
actes en cohérence avec ses belles
paroles bien plus utille aux femmes avec
la remise en place des centres d'IVG
chez les républicains nous respectons
sur ces questions un principe
fondamental la liberté de conscience
absolue et de vote pour chacun de nos
députés je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la Paro est ant
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le garde des saau
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté garantie à la femme d'avoir
recours à une interruption volontaire de
grossesse telle est la rédaction qui
nous est soumise aujourd'hui pour ce
vote
solennel avec ces mots que nous nous
apprêtons à faire rentrer dans la
Constitution nous avons rendez-vous
aujourd'hui avec l'histoire r
rendez-vous avec l'histoire de la
construction de l'égalité femme- homme
rendez-vous aussi avec l'histoire de nos
grands-mères de nos mères rendez-vous
avec l'histoire de nos filles de nos
petites filles cette rédaction est j'en
suis convaincu la plus aboutie elle est
sans nul doute possible la plus
protectrice pour toutes les femmes de ce
pays et s'il fallait encore le rappeler
je vous dirais que cette écriture est le
fruit d'un équilibre entre les positions
de notre assemblée et le Sénat elle
retient les mots interruption volontaire
de grossesse afin de ne laisser
substituer aucune ambigué elle consacre
l'existence d'une liberté qu' à l'esprit
de la loi de Simone veille de 1975
elle reconnaît le rôle du Parlement dans
l'établissement des conditions dans
lesquelles s'exerce cette liberté
garantie par la Constitution alors sous
couvert d'un d'une soi-disant meilleure
protection des femmes et de leurs
intérêts certains s'inquiètent qu'aucune
limite ne soit explicitement mentionnée
dans la Constitution sur ce point je me
contenterai seulement de vous relire
l'avis du Conseil d'État le Conseil
d'État considère que cette rédaction
comme le souhaite le gouvernement laisse
au législateur la possibilité de faire
évoluer le cadre juridique dans lequel
s'exerce cette liberté en en fixant les
garanties et les limites et dans le
respect des principes de sauvegarde de
la dignité de la personne humaine et de
la liberté de la femme sous le contrôle
du Conseil
constitutionnel je sais que ces derniers
temps la tendance est à la remise en
cause de nos institutions mais arrêtons
un instant ces postures politique
considérons cette décision comme elle
doit l'être et admettons que oui les
parlementaires que nous sommes pourront
fixer les limites juridique de cette
liberté mais en votant ce texte nous ne
reviendrons jamais en arrière donc à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
considèrent comme encore aujourd'hui
après les multiples débats que nous
avons pu avoir en commission des lois et
en séance à l'Assemblée nationale ainsi
aussi bien qu'au Sénat où chacun a pu
développer ses revendications et ses
argumentaires considérons que cette
rédaction manque de ceci ou de cela je
dirais que le temps n'est plus à la
casuistique prenons nos responsabilités
et votons pour la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG alors je peux comprendre la
volonté de certains de nos collègues d'y
ajouter la
contraception toutefois je ne pense pas
qu'elle y ait sa place aujourd'hui cela
d'ailleurs risquerait de nous priver
d'adoption d'un d'une même écriture au
Sénat en nous privant des facto d'un
vote au Congrès dans les mois qui
viennent je vous rejoins toutefois sur
un point essentiel ces deux combats sont
effectivement intimement liés et nos
politiques doivent permettre de protéger
sa bonne information et son accès pour
toutes les femmes qui souhaitent y avoir
recours le groupe démocrate y sera
vigilant l'histoire nous montre que les
grands débats qui ont divisé un moment
les Français apparaissent avec le recul
du temps comme une étape nécessaire à la
formation d'un consensus social qui
s'inscrit dans la tradition de tolérance
et de mesure de notre pays en ce jour
historique ces mots de Simon veille
raisonnent encore plus vivement dans
notre hémicycle alors comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure en mémoire de nos
grands-mères qui ont tant souffert de ne
pas avoir ce droit à qui la la liberté
de disposer de leur corps a tant manqué
et demain pour garantir ce droit à nos
filles et nos petites filles écrivons un
nouveau chapitre dans l'histoire des
droits des femmes le groupe démocrate
votera pour la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG merci beaucoup mon cher
[Applaudissements]
collègue la parole est à Madame Marie
Noël btistel pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous y sommes la semaine dernière à
cette même tribune les orateurs se sont
succédés pour dire leurs intimes
convictions
sur ce projet de loi constitutionnel
relatif à la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
durant les débats nous avons pu redire
notre fierté et notre engagement de voir
graver dans le marbre constitutionnel ce
droit acquis de haute lutte certes nous
avons aussi entendu sur certains de ces
bancs les soubressau réactionnaires de
ceux qui osent à peine dire le fond de
leur pensé néanmoins ce débat nous aura
permis de montrer que la représentation
nation peut-être à la hauteur des
aspirations profondes autant que des
préoccupations quotidiennes des Français
être au rendez-vous de l'histoire n'est
pas si aisé et demande tout à la fois la
force des convictions et le temps de
l'écoute la fermeté sur les principes et
la souplesse pour trouver des
compromis le texte même s'il est
imparfait ouvre la voie mobilise les
conscienceces et marquera durablement
l'histoire du droit des femmes dans
notre pays et bien au-delà c'est un
honneur que de porter la parole de mon
groupe et de contribuer avec vous tous à
écrire une nouvelle page de notre
histoire féministe une page que les
associations et mouvements féministes
ont chapitré depuis longtemps une page
de la grande histoire qui est avant tout
une épreuve du quotidien écrite par
celles et ceux qui loin des couleurs de
de couloir de l'Assemblée nationale se
battent pour faire de l'avortement un
droit réel et effectif qu'il soit
remercié pour le cap qu'ils ont su tenir
malgré les vents contraires cette
victoire est la
vôtre c'est aussi c'est aussi un grand
jour pour nous socialistes qui avont
porté plusieurs lois visant à renforcer
et protéger l'IVG merci à Cécile
ununtermeyer Fatia kelouashi et Laurence
Rossignol qui n'ont eu de cesse de se
battre comme moi pour cette
cause le résultat est aussi le fruit
d'un travail collectif autour du texte
de la présidente Mathilde Panau qui a
été adoptée il y a quelques mois
je salue également mes collègues Elsa
fussillon et Marie-Charlotte Garin pour
leur
engagement enfin je remercie le
rapporteur Guillaume Gouffier Valence
qui mène ce combat depuis longtemps et
sur qui nous avons pu nous
appuyer lors de mon intervention
liminaire je vous avais exhorté à faire
triompher la vigilance celle
indispensable que Simone de bevoir
appelé de ses vœux pour défendre les
droits des femmes qui ne sont finalement
jamais acquis
le texte proposé est donc bien celui de
la vigilance face notamment à ceux qui
prétendent que le droit à l'avortement
n'est pas menacé en France
oui le droit à l'avortement peut-être
entravé chez nous à l'image de ce qui se
passe dans des pays où
celui-ci pourtant paraissait hors
d'atteinte la Pologne la Hongrie le
Portugal pour ne citer que qui peut ici
préjuger de ce qu'il pourrait advenir
demain dans notre pays alors que des
propos particulièrement inquiétants ont
été réitérés avec insistance de ce
côté-ci de
l'hémicycle qui peut aussi nier que les
entraves à l'IVG prennent des formes de
plus en plus pernicieuses de la part des
mouvements antidroit
oui la constitutionnalisation conférera
un niveau de protection juridique accru
en venant protéger ce qu'une simple loi
pourrait défaire demain la loi des lois
est effectivement la norme su me qui
fonde le socle des valeurs et fait la
force d'une République indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale oui la
constitutionnalisation des droits
reproductifs viendra renforcer la
promesse d'égalité réelle en
sanctuarisant la liberté des femmes à
disposer librement de leur corps et non
le droit à l'avortement ne bénéficie pas
encore d'un niveau de protection
juridique renforcée non il ne jouit pas
d'une protection constitutionnelle
autonome et non il n'a jamais été
consacré par le juge constitutionnel ni
par le juge européen dans la catégorie
des droits
fondamentaux certes ce texte est
imparfait et la consécration de l'IVG
aurait pu être plus forte par une une
rédaction plus ambitieuse nous aurions
préféré inscrire à l'article 1 un droit
fondamental plutôt qu'une liberté
garantie et une mention à l'accès à la
contraception pourtant pour autant nous
savons que les victoires F ministes ont
toujours été le fruit de compromis dès
lors que l'on peut obtenir gain de cause
sur l'essentiel alors parce qu'il est
important de mettre sévèrement en échec
ceux qui combattent le droit des femmes
parce que des millions de femmes
aujourd'hui et demain attendent un
signal fort parce que partout dans le
monde la voie tracée par la France est
regardé et suivie de près lorsqu'il
s'agit de protéger des droits
fondamentaux parce que nous avons le
droit des femmes chevillé au corps et
finalement parce que le cela est juste
et nécessaire les socialistes voteront à
avec fierté ce projet de loi
constitutionnel pour contribuer à faire
de ce jour une grande victoire féministe
je vous remercie ma chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Anne
Cécile violent pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le garde des saut monsieur le Président
de la Commission monsieur le rapporteur
chers
collègues en ce 30 janvier
2024 nous
députés représentants du peuple devons
nous prononcer en not tram et conscience
sur la constitutionnalisation de la
liberté de la femme à recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse cette constitutionnalisation
pose des questions qui sont légitimes et
auquel ils nous font
répondre la première d'entre elles est
est-il nécessaire d'inscrire cette
liberté au sein de notre norme suprême
alors même qu'elle n'est pas
structurellement menacée en France
oui d'abord et avant tout parce que vous
le savez comme moi le jour où cette
liberté sera réellement menacé il sera
trop tard anticiper les risques c'est
comme bâtir un rempart avant
l'assaut en outre vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'assise sur une simple loi
ordinaire cette liberté est en réalité
bien plus fragile qu'elle n'y paraît
elle est réversible au gré de la
composition de C cet
hémicycle comme le rappelle le Conseil
d'État elle ne fait l'objet d'aucune
consécration en tant que tel ni dans
notre Constitution ni dans la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et pas
d'avantage dans le droit de l'Union
européenne or nous avons pu le constater
aux États-Unis comme en Europe ce que
l'on pensait acquis dans nos sociétés
modernes ne l'est jamais
définitivement surtout surtout lorsque
l'on parle de droits des
femmes le temps est venu de lui
consacrer une valeur constitutionnelle
autonome je crois que aussi à travers
cette
constitutionnalisation c'est un message
envoyé aux femmes de France et du monde
entier mesdames votre liberté de choisir
fait partie intégrante des valeurs
fondamentales de notre pays votre corps
n'est pas un territoire à réguler mais
plutôt un espace sacré de libre arbitre
et
d'autodétermination une autre question
c'est régulièrement invitée dans nos
débats il est essentiel d'y répondre
clairement la consécration de cette
liberté aura-t-elle pour conséquence de
créer une liberté inconditionnelle de
recourir à l'IVG pourrait-elle remettre
en cause la clause de conscience des
médecins la réponse est
non comme tout droit ou liberté
fondamentale la liberté de recourir à
l'IVG à voocation à être concilié avec
d'autres droits fondamentaux que
contiennent nos normes suprêmes par
exemple à ceux qui s'inquiètent de la
création d'un éventuel déséquilibre
entre deux principes à valeur
constitutionnelles que sont la liberté
de la femme et la sauvegarde de la
dignité de la personne humaine contre
toute forme de
dégradation je leur réponds que ce n'est
nullement l'intention de ce projet de
loi ce projet de loi a un seul but
encadrer l'office du législateur afin
qu'il ne puisse interdire tout recours à
l'IVG ni en restreindre les conditions
d'exercice de façon telle qu'il
priverait cette liberté de toute portée
de la même manière et comme le dit
extrêmement clairement le Conseil d'État
l'inscription de la liberté de recourir
à une IVG dans la Constitution dans les
termes que propose le gouvernement ne
remet pas davantage en cause la liberté
constitutionnelle de conscience qui
soutend la liberté des médecins et des
sages-femmes de ne pas pratiquer cette
interruption volontaire de grossesse
enfin une question non moins essentielle
et mettant en lumière finalement
l'ensemble des interrogations que
soutend cette
constitutionnalisation la rédaction
proposée par le gouvernement est-elle la
bonne elle n'est certes probablement pas
parfaite pour tout le monde mais je
crois que le consensus tient en chacun
de ces mots elle est le fruit de travail
de long terme mené par l'assemblée des
parlementaires de l'Assemblée comme du
Sénat au sein de nos assemblées
respectives nous nous sommes interrogés
longuement
sur sa place s'il fallait consacrer un
droit ou une liberté sur le choix de
chacun des mots pour s'assurer de lui
donner sa pleine force mais à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat ces
propositions de loi constitutionnelles
ont été adoptées preuve qu'un consensus
existe la rédaction qui nous est soumise
aujourd'hui est selon moi la meilleure
synthèse des préoccupations des uns et
des autres il est important de le
rappeler pour autant ce projet de loi ne
peut et ne doit occulter la disparité de
réalité d'accès à l'IVG et invite à
encore plus de vigilance sur le
déploiement des centres IBG parce qu'il
consacre la liberté de la femme la
protection de ses choix et le rôle des
représentant du peuple dans la fixation
du cadre dans lesquel C liberté s'exerce
le groupe horizon et apparenté votera en
faveur de ce projet de loi avec force et
conviction je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma cher
collèg je
vous jeis annonc in de l'Assemblée
nationale pour le groupe écologiste la
parole est à Madame Sandrine
[Applaudissements]
Rousseau madame la
présidente Madame et monieurs les
ministres chers
collègues non non pas de nom de quoi le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans la Constitution est-il le
nom dans les débats que nous avons eu
ici vous à la droite et à l'extrême
droite avez dit que le droit à l'IVG
n'était pas en danger en France vous
avez dit que le recours à l'IVG
progresser vous avez de mil et une
manière cité Simone veille vous n'avez
retenu qu'une partie de ce discours vous
avez surtout insisté sur le fait que
c'était un drame ce que nous avons endu
c'est que peut-être au fond
souhaiteriez-vous que cela en reste un
un
drame vous avez évoqué l'accompagnement
supposément nécessaire aux femmes pour
être sûr de faire le bon choix vous avez
souvent posé le terme
d'exception cela doit rester une
exception avez-vous dit je voudrais
poser ici tranquillement mais fermement
que tous ces mots contribu
insidieusement souterrainement aux
atteintes à la liberté des femmes à
recourir à
l'IVG car il contribue à penser qu'il
aurait pu y avoir d'autres solutions
supposément de meilleur non tu n'as pas
d'existence tu n'es que ce qu'on en
pense les femmes n'ont pas besoin que
cela soit un drame pour recourir à l'IVG
elles ont ce droit et en conscience
elles l'exercent les femmes n'ont pas à
expliciter ou à justifier de leur choix
à une personne tierce ce choix leur
appartient absolument intimement
effectivement les femmes n'ont pas n'ont
pas avoir le parcours de l'IVG compliqué
par l'éloignement du centre de soins ou
la nécessité que cela soit une exception
si une femme décide d'avorter alors
c'est à la société de s'adapter pour lui
garantir ce droit non tu n'as pas de nom
au nom tu n'es pas un être intégré g
dans la Constitution c'est passé de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme aux
droits humains c'est posé que le
masculin n'est pas un neutre et que la
liberté se décline sur nos corps de
manière différente
oui cette garantie là doit nous être
propre ce n'est pas une petite décision
dans bien des endroits du monde la
France sera regardée et peut-être ici ou
là des féministes d'autres parlements
ailleurs déposeront à leur tour une
proposition de loi comme un bâton de
relais invisible que nous nous passons
de femm en femme tu le deviendrais
peut-être si je te donnais asile si
c'était moins difficile nous aurions
préféré bien sûr que la formulation dans
la loi soit encore plus protectrice nous
aurions aimé que les termes intègrent la
notion de droit et non juste de recours
nous aurions aimé que la loi évoque la
contraception cela aurait déplacé le
débat de l'IVG
strictu au droit des femmes à disposer
de leur corps en général nous aurions
aimé que les personnes trans soient
mieux incluses dans la formulation
finale mais c'est une première étape
merci à Mélanie Vogel et à Mathilde pan
pour leurs textes
[Applaudissements]
iniici'ilattend endre impossible de
clore ce débat sur l'IVG sans saluer
l'action historique ancienne et
constante des association féministe au
premier rang desquel le MLF et le
Mouvement français pour le planning
familial vous savez cette grande et
vieille association que des militantes
du droit des femmes ont créé fait vivre
et développer depuis
1960 ce planning installé partout et qui
qui dispense conseil et accès aux soins
vous savez cette association qui est
attaquée par des militants de l'extrême
droite antiivg de Strasbourg à Bordeaux
et dont certains élus de droite coupent
discrètement les subventions dès qu'ils
en ont l'occasion impossible de terminer
sans saluer ses médecins et ses figures
de la lutte avocat femmees politique
philosoph artistes difficile de toutes
les cités si ce n'était un piège et quel
douloureux sortilège non non tu n'as pas
de nom C ver son d'ne Sylvestre le
moment pour moi de dire merci aux
féministes des vagues précédentes de
celles qui ont été gavées et pour
certaines en sont mortes pour obtenir
simplement le droit à aller voter les
suffragettes à celles qui se sont battu
pour le droit à la contreception et à
l'IVG au droit à n'être pas réduite au
fait de faire des enfants à ne pas
devoir réarmer quoi que ce soit jusqu'à
celle aujourd'hui à vous mes sœurs à
vous qui portez Sion les couleurs De
Mitou merci beaucoup madame la député
ils nous ont raillé critiqué jugé
dangereuse folle ou hystérique mais
toujours nous avons gagner alors que le
combat continue nous écologistes V ce
texte je vous remercie madame la
députée la parole la parole est à Madame
Soumia bouroua pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine merci merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur ne jamais baisser la garde ne
jamais penser que les droits que nous
avons si durement acquis nous serons
toujours assuré oui le combat pour le
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps est plus que jamais d'actualité
dans notre pays il suffit de voir les
moyens déployés par les opposants à
l'IVG pour comprend que ce débat n'est
pas terminé encore aujourd'hui ce sont
les mêmes qui s'opposent à l'éducation à
la sexualité et à la vie affective les
mêmes qui subventionnent des plateformes
de désinformation sur la contraception
et l'avortement les mêmes qui
culpabilise les femmes pour qu'elles
renonce à
avorter le projet de loi sur lequel nous
allons prononcer ce soir intervient dans
un contexte particulier où des millions
de femmes dans le monde ont vu leur
droit cliner nous ne pouvons pas baisser
la
garde ce soir nous pouvons inscrire un
droit fondamental dans notre
Constitution celui de garantir aux
femmes la liberté d'avoir recours à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse à
travers ce vote nous serions parmi les
premiers pays au monde à protéger ce
droit aussi fermement et je seraiis fier
de cette
avancée
pour mon groupe et moi-même ce vote est
tout sauf anecdotique il s'inscrit dans
une lignée d'un long combat féministe et
je voudrais rendre ici hommage à ces
femmes à ces militantes à ces
associations qui se sont batttu pour
l'accès libre à la contraception et pour
la légalisation de
l'avortement j'en profite pour les
applaudir cela fait maintenant près de
50 ans qu'avorter n'est plus un crime en
1974 Simon veille prenait la parole dans
cet hémicycle pour défendre un projet de
loi qu'elle qualifiait de solution à la
fois réaliste humaines et injustes pour
répondre à la souffrance de ces femmes
qui avortaient clandestinement grâce à
elle enfin nous avions le choix si cela
fait près de 50 ans que ces femmes ne
meurent plus en avortant c'est parce que
la loi française les protège plusieurs
générations de femmes ont souffert de ne
pas avoir ce choix plusieurs générations
de femmes sont mortes parce qu'elles
voulaient faire le choix de ne pas
enfanter de ne pas devenir maire
malheureusement nous voyons bien que ce
droit est toujours remis en cause par
celles et ceux qui n'accorderont jamais
de nouveaux droits aux femmes ce droit
est remis en question par celles et ceux
qui en réalité ont une vision
conservatrice de la de la femme pardon
dans notre
société aux états Unis il a suffit d'un
arrêt de la Cour suprême pour que le
droit à l'avortement soit remis en cause
il a suffit d'un arrêt pour que 14 États
interdisent l'avortement plus près de
nous en Pologne en Hongrie l'extrême
droite au pouvoir s'en prend violemment
aux droits des femmes et à travers ces
exemples nous voyons bien que le der que
cela représente y compris en France
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
voulons pas attendre que ce risque se
transforme en réalité pour agir c'est
pourquoi nous ne voulons pas que ces
droits si chèrement acquis ne soient
confisqué ce projet de loi
constitutionnel est une nécessité pour
autant il faut continuer il faut
garantir partout sur le territoire
l'accès effectif à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse en y mettant les
moyens nécessaires ce projet de loi
constitutionnel pose des difficultés à
celle qui en réalité ne défendront
jamais le droit à l'avortement et qui
jamais ne garantiront aux femmes leur
indépendance le combat du groupe GDR
s'inscrit pour les droits des femmes
dans les grandes lutte féministe d'hier
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et parce que
jamais nous ne baisserons la garde nous
voterons pour ce projet de loi
constitutionnel merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue
[Applaudissements]
je vais demander à chacun d'entre vous
de bien vouloir regagner sa
place le je vais donc mettre au voie le
projet de loi le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 546
exprimé 523 majorité 262 pour 493 contre
30 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté et je vais donner la parole à
monsieur le garde des saau ministre de
la
Justice
madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés
madame la ministre cher
Aurore ce
soir l'Assemblée nationale et le
gouvernement n'ont pas manqué leur
rendez-vous avec l'histoire des
femmes ce
soir l'Assemblée nationale et le
gouvernement n'ont pas manqué leur
rendez-vous avec l'histoire tout court
PLT je vais maintenant
m'atteler apporter le message qui est le
vôtre au
Sénat je vais convaincre le Sénat avec
détermination humilité et naturellement
avec tout le respect que l'on doit à
toutes les consciences que cette réforme
est une réforme
utile convaincre le Sénat que c'est une
réforme juste je vais m'atteler à
convaincre le Sénat que cette réforme
nous la devons à toutes les femmes de
notre pays convaincre le Sénat qu'il est
grand temps en 2024 d'inscrire dans la
Constitution que la liberté d'avorter
pour les femmes est une liberté
fondamentale et que les femmes peuvent
disposer comme elles
l'entendent
merci beaucoup monsieur le garde desau
la séance est
suspendue